so today I want to talk about what's the
difference between a start-up CEO versus
an established
CEO I'm Patrick whatever your host of IT
team and weekly and when we look at this
question here what's the difference
between a start-up you know a CEO in a
in a established CEO the best example I
can think about is Steve Jobs versus Tim
Cook of a same company Apple right so on
one side they are complete opposite type
of CEOs you have Steve Jobs on one side
that's a start-up CEO which he is driven
by crisis Tim Cook is driven by
stability you know on performance Steve
Jobs is driven by being unpredictable
Tim Cook is driven by being predictable
Steve Jobs is driven by hoarding cash
Tim Cook has cash he wants to spend cash
so Steve Jobs got a lot of criticism for
hoarding cash why because as a start-up
entrepreneur when you're there and
you're going through it and you realize
how close you are to go out of business
you see the value of having cash on hand
because when you don't have that that's
when you go out of business so a Tim
Cook does not know what it is to go
through that he comes in to cash so he
is more open to one acquire companies
kind of like Tim Cook is thinking about
buying the company by dre beats he wants
to buy that company why because they
have access to cash to go acquire
another company and pay him 3.2 billion
dollars while jobs want everything to be
self created inside up inside up
complete different ways of thinking
about it now who is Right who is wrong
who is better who is weaker that in both
of them both of them are needed there is
not one that's more important the other
obviously a Steve Jobs gives birth to
the opportunity which is very very
important but Tim Cook comes and
stabilizes that opportunity which
investors like to see a company with
stability one drives the other one needs
to know how to drive and stabilize
together but have done the right way you
can have an incredible opportunity for
them to do so it's just knowing the
a Tim Cook wouldn't make a start-up CEO
and a Steve Jobs would not necessarily
make the best established CEO with no
crisis to solve if you position them
properly you have a vent winning formula
for that company and organization
it's my message of the week Jim please
be sure to subscribe to the channel and
comment on the bottom you the best thing
focus we don't have them Tim Cook
believes in acquisition accuracy accuse
accusation acquisition accusation is not
what it is okay alright Betty
ready